joining us now Treasury secretary
Stephen minuchin mr. secretary welcome
back to Fox News Sunday Chris great to
be back with you the official
unemployment rate as we just reported
for April is fourteen point seven
percent but that does not include the
seven million jobs loss since April 18th
were the millions of workers not looking
for jobs were what are called the
underemployed so mr. secretary what is
the real unemployment rate in the United
States as we talked today Chris there
the real issue and the president and I
understand this is the economic issues
that American workers and American
business are facing as a result of this
virus and the decision to close the
economy and that's the reason why the
president wants to work with the states
to safely reopen the economy so we can
safely get people back to work so these
these are very very large numbers these
are not large numbers because of the
economy wasn't doing well these are
large numbers because we've shut down
the economy and I would just highlight
the biggest component of this was in
travel and retail and leisure and not a
surprise we've closed down major parts
of the economy I'm gonna get into that
with you in a moment but I think it's
important that we face what the real
numbers are the Bureau of Labor
Statistics says what they call the real
unemployment number for April which
again includes people who are not
looking for work or underemployed is
22.8% but again that does not include
because the unemployment numbers for
April stopped in mid-april does not
include the 7 million people who have
lost their jobs since then so aren't we
talking close to 25% at this point which
is great depression at neighborhood
Chris we could be but let me just
emphasize unlike the Great Depression
where you had economic issues that led
to this we closed down the economy so
it's it's it wouldn't be a surprise if
you closed down the economy that and
half of the workforce is half the people
didn't work and and that's why we're
very focused on rebuilding this economy
and getting
get back to where it was this is no
fault of American business this is no
fault of American workers this is a
result of a virus and that's why the
President and I were determined to put
together the largest economic program
ever to help American workers get
through this so you are correct the
reported numbers are probably going to
get worse before they get better but
that's why we're focused on rebuilding
this economy will have a better third
quarter will have a better fourth
quarter and next year is going to be a
great year well let's talk about that
because you and the president both say
the economy is going to come roaring
back but I got to tell you now when I
asked you about a number of signs which
indicate that the recovery is going to
be much slower than that sir
job losses are not just in the
hospitality industry Airlines
restaurants as you would expect but
they're more widespread the white collar
and government sector three million jobs
lost major retailers like Neiman Marcus
and j.crew declaring bankruptcy and the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
as unemployment at the end not of this
year but a 2021 will still be nine and a
half percent question are your rosy
predictions based on economic reality or
the November election Chris let me just
emphasize first of all these numbers
impact real people and I want to
emphasize we understand what this is how
this is impacting real people so they're
not just numbers it's impacting real
people my numbers aren't rosy what I've
said is you're gonna have a very very
bad second quarter and then I think
you're gonna see a bounce back from a
low standpoint none of the economic
models have ever worked in predicting
what happens when you close down due to
medical reasons
so my predictions are based upon what I
see is the rate of reopening in a
careful way it's also based upon my
views and I've personally heard from
many of the doctors that have vaccines
and virals in trials and their
expectations of being able to get a
vaccine by the end of this year and
having real viral tree
the advent of testing all these things
are going to help give American business
and American workers the confidence to
reopen in a careful in a deliberate way
and what about the food supply chain
that that farmers and processors say is
broken because they can't get their meat
and they can't get their produce from
the field to market well Chris those
those are real issues but again let me
emphasize I see the glass as half full
and not half empty if you had told the
American public we would virtually shut
down the entire supply chains and still
be able to feed America and get drugs to
America and continue to do critical work
I couldn't be more pleased how Americans
are pulling together to get through this
so yes there are issues we're working
through those issues the task force is
focusing on these issues when we see
them we're figuring out how to fix them
now the president is calling for States
to reopen and a number of Governors are
around the country but this week the
president talked about the possible cost
of that take a look well some people be
affected yes well some people be
affected badly yes but we have to get
our country open and we have to get it
open soon
but Patrick harker head of the
Philadelphia Federal Reserve says if the
economy opens too soon and the virus
spikes again quote not only would this
be a health catastrophe but it would
reverse the recovery as well if that
happens he predicts quote a painful
economic contraction of GDP and 2021 as
shutdowns are reintroduced do you agree
that there is a considerable risk not to
say you shouldn't do it but there is a
considerable risk of reopening both from
a public health and an economic
standpoint Chris if we do this carefully
working with the governors I don't think
there's a considerable risk matter of
fact I think there's a considerable risk
of not reopening you're talking about
what would be permanent economic damage
to the American public and we're going
to reopen in a very thoughtful way that
gets people back to work safely that has
them social distance one of the things
we've seen chris is a lot of businesses
can do telework not everybody has to
come back into the office at the same
time but people will be able to go into
stores some of them will have
reservations when they go in but
businesses will be able to reopen and I
think as you know certain parts of the
country had very devastating impacts
like New York in certain parts of the
country didn't and this is all being
monitored very very carefully let's turn
to the question of what the if there's
going to be a another response from
Washington if so what it's going to be
huh Speaker Nancy Pelosi says she may
introduce a phase for relief bill this
week but lauren Kudlow the white house
economic advisor said this week that the
administration wants to wait until late
May or early June to decide where to go
next and here's the president on that
subject this week the Democrats have to
do what they have to do but I would say
we're we're not looking we want to see
what they have but I can't say that word
unless we were to rush to get the money
out to people we have gotten the money
out question with 33 million people
unemployed with the Paycheck protection
program money running out by the end of
this month with state budgets cratering
this administration is in no rush well
Chris the president I have been very
clear on this and we're in a hundred
percent agreement first let me just say
we appreciate the enormous bipartisan
support that both parties in the house
and the Senate worked together to get an
unprecedented response you're talking of
over three trillion dollars into the
economy you're talking about another two
and a half to five trillion dollars
working with the Federal Reserve this
has never been done before and I just
want to emphasize and thank the
bipartisan support
what the president and I are now saying
is we spent a lot of money a lot of this
money is not even into the economy yet
let's take the next few weeks I'm having
discussions with both the Republicans
and the Democrats to understand these
issues the president and I are having
conversations with outside people with
business we just want to make sure that
before we jump back in and spend another
few trillion of taxpayers money that we
do it carefully we had an emergency
process it work quickly we're there to
help the American people we're going to
be considerate and if we need to help
the American people in every aspect of
this as I've said before we're willing
to spend whatever it takes but whatever
it takes needs to be done carefully I
got about a minute left and I think I
want to squeeze this in the president
says that he won't sign another relief
bill without a payroll tax cut in it but
both Democrats and a lot of top
Republicans are expressing grave
concerns about that because they say a
payroll tax cut doesn't help if
somebody's unemployed and they're not on
a payroll and here's what the Senate
Republican leader Mitch McConnell had to
say about that I think I can safely say
for our team here the Republican Senate
majority if there's any red line it's on
litigation litigation of course means
liability protection that if somebody
goes back to worker goes into a
restaurant that they wouldn't be able to
sue to say that they got the virus from
that place so given the the hesitancy
from the Republicans and Democrats on
Capitol Hill will the president will do
you insist that a payroll tax cut be
part of the next relief though well
we're absolutely pushing for the payroll
tax cut it's an incentive to get people
back to work it's it's delivering money
to the American public and to business
in a very effective way and that will be
one of the components you've heard Mitch
McConnell talk about liability we agree
with that completely the the Democrats
have been asking for more money for
states we've been very clear that we're
not going to do things just to bail out
states that were poorly managed
but we're gonna look at all these issues
and Chris let me just emphasize all
these bills have had enormous bipartisan
support when we need to go back and work
and get help the American public will do
this in a bipartisan way and make sure
we get all these things included
secretary Minuten thank you thanks for
your time today always good to talk with
you sir thank you